Gary was in LA for the
Grammys Mr hobnob he do there oh my God
you should see this guy's itin oh yeah
he needed to be at the Grammys yeah he
he spent all weekend hobnobbing with
Hollywood celebrities here's Gary's uh
agenda these are just some of the events
Gary attended he saw you two at the
sphere in Las Vegas wow he went to the
Bon Joi event music haes music haes it's
a night where everybody all these famous
people do bonjovi songs and so what
happens is all these big people get up
so like um jelly roll did a bonjovi song
uh Bruce Springsteen and John came out
together to do a song Sammy hagard did a
bonjovi song Oh John must have been
celling I mean uh he loves it he curated
the whole night I asked about it he I
said you know how involved were you with
who gets to perform he goes I handpicked
everyone what were you doing there were
you the working the Cod check or I mean
like What's your deal no I was
you go to the coil party youo with
agents and stuff and then you know then
I was sitting at a table when when John
was curating the event he said hm who
can I cut to cooch that would be sort of
fun to look at when people walk in and
they got G accurated the
chocolate then he went to a Clive Davis
party that's the big that's why is Big
because again he gets everybody in the
music industry to perform and it's all
over the place so like Green Day opened
but then sza performed and the Public
Enemy
performed what song did they do Public
Enemy they did fight the power and uh I
can't remember I can't remember the
other song was flave up there oh yeah
yeah I spent the bulk of the weekend
with flave because uh Thursday night was
Ross zap's birthday party and I don't
know how but Ross and flavor flave are
like best buddies what did Sammy perform
at the John bonjovi event I'm trying to
remember it I think it was Living on a
Prayer
but I can't remember it was one of like
one of the big here you go it's You Give
Love a Bad Name oh uh Wolf Gang Van
Halen played was great it was great yeah
what did he
play God I don't again he doesn't know
were you there of course but I don't
remember every song that everybody did
if you took some notes write down what
you don't know what wolf you said wolf
game van alen was impressive what song
did he
do I didn't have my phone I don't
know what the [__] only when I have my
phone can I get names so I can name
drop so I can be Mr big
shot what the what what good is sending
Gary to these events he doesn't even
know what he
saw probably probably
wasted I got it right here Melissa
Ethridge did Blaze of Glory jelly roll
did Bad Medicine lady Wilson who's a big
country store said we weren't born to
follow um Jason is buil that wanted Dead
or Alive the only question I asked you
was what did Wolf Gang Van Halen do
still haven't gotten have a nice day
song is called have a nice day okay I
know the song Gary's the B she goes I
tell you both it was incredible a once
in a lifetime night but I don't remember
a thing about
it why is that well it's hard to
remember it was just great wolf G Hal
was [__] great oh yeah what do you do
I don't know I don't know I got
chocolate on my
notes Bruce Bruce I'm sorry about my
breath you guys are you guys are you
guys are genuine [__] Bruce I'm the
author of They Call Me baba buoy would
you like an autograph copy I can get it
for you Howard the show was awesome I
think I don't know I can't remember any
of
it